how were you able to create this moment
and secure this SEC Championship with
your team when we talk about level
falling back to level of training the
offseason grind it come it all comes
into games like this you know I'm proud
of proud of the whole team because at
the end of the day the biggest thing we
did they try to get 1% better and never
give up but when you think about your
personal Journey you go back to Texas
you go back to getting replaced in week
three and then you create this moment
how have you been able to lead to this
success keep the main thing the main
thing before anybody had an opinion on
me I had my purpose already so the
biggest thing was just stay true to
myself and I had the right support
system around me to uplift me
congratulations chayen thank you roll
tie